السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره اخفقا وزراء الطاقه الاوروبيون
خلال اجتماعهم في بروكسل في الاتفاق على
تحديد سقف لاسعار الغاز وذلك للمره
الخامسه واجل الوزراء الاوروبيون حسما
موضوع التحديدي سقف لاسعار الغاز الى
اجتماعهم يوم الاثنين المقبل
واتواجه فرنسا والمانيا ودول شمال اوروبا
تقسم شديد البروده الى زياده طلب على
الطاقه وذكر موقعه
بارده في اوروبا
لمحطات الطاقه للحفاظ على اضواء المنطقه
قال مسؤولون امريكيون واشنطن تضعوا لمسات
الاخيره على خطط لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ باتريوت للدفاع الجوي واضاف
المسؤولون الامريكيون قد تعلنوا ارسال هذه
الصواريخ الى اوكرانيا خلال الاسبوع
الجاري على ان يتم تدريب الاوكرانيين على
استخدامها في قاعده للجيش الامريكيه
من جهتها اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه في
تغريده ان رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
للدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50 مليون
جنيه
واضافتنا حزمه المساعدات الجديده
لاوكرانيا تتالف من 125 متر مضاده
للطائرات والتكنولوجيا لمواجهه المسيره
الايراني
وقال ديمترميد فيديف نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي انه اذا قام نيته بحسب ما
لمح الامين العام للحلف يانس ستايلندرج
بتزويد من وصفهم بالمتعصبين في كيف
بمنظمات باتريوت مع عناصر من قوه الناتو
فسيصبحون على الفور هدفا مشروعا للقوات
الروسيه
اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للتضامن مع اوكرانيا تعاهدوا بتقديم اكثر
من مليار يورو لكيف كدعم مالين وعينيا
خلال فصل الشتاء الجاري وكشفت عن وضع
اليات جديده سميت اليه باريس لتنظيم
وتنسيق الدعم الدولي والمساعدات
الاوكرانيا جاء ذلك في اختتام عمل المؤتمر
بمشاركه الست واربعين دوله
واربعين وعشرين منظمه دوليه من بينها
الامم المتحده
انتخب الكنيسه الطبيه اغلبيه 64 صوتا يعرف
الليفن من حزب الكود رئيسا مؤقتا للكنيست
وذلك بعد عزل الرئيس الحالي الميكي ليفي
المحسوب على حكومه تصريف العمل ويسعى
ليكون الى السيطره على الكنيست لتمريره
تعديلات قانونيه قبل الاعلان عن تشكيل
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو ومن بين التعديلات
شرعيه على تعينيه رئيس حركه الشمس
وادخال تعديلات تمكن عضوي الكنيسه
المتطرفين كثير وبتسل الصاموليتش من
توسيعي صلاحيتهما في وزارتي الامن القوميه
والدفاع
ووصف مخاوف متزايده من صعود الاحزاب
الدينيه قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه
المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو ان اسرائيل لن
تتحول في عهده الى دوله اصليه دينيه بل
ستبقى دوله لكل مواطنيها وفق تعبيره
في خطوه تؤذن بتحول تاريخي في انتاج
الطاقه النظيفه بما فيها الكهرباء قالت
وزيره الطاقه الامريكيه ان علماء امريكيين
تمكنوا لاول مره في التاريخ من تحقيق
اندماج النووي نتجت عنه طاقه اكبر من
الطاقه التي يحتاجها الاندماجه واعتبرت
الوزيره الامريكيه لاكتشاف اخترقا عمليا
قد يمثلوا الثوره في مصادر الطاقه النظيفه
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه لما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير